ladies and gentlemen and your Marconi
thank you thank you thank you very much
Wally Rosario academia Perko solo reggae
Maya fatto
van OVA Cousteau envied Fred para
volleyer Ingrid sorry on k2 Tukwila
Gallo Venuto quest abrenio perm a Forte
meant a yellow sentido profundamente
diggin cheddar yes I will tell you what
he sang and he wants to thank the
Academy and all the people who really
truly wanted to have this great honor
sir event a volley or Ingrid sorry
Octavia registry logistic America motto
kilala fiducia Oscar bream UCL or o
filmer veramente euros are equi
sarahpearl or oh yeah his deep gratitude
goes to all the directors who had faith
in Him without them he says he wouldn't
be here today
my pet serova are ka2 Tilly artiste
a.k.a no merit Otto
questo premio a Carano Guto yogoro
Diavolo you know prosavana she no futuro
his thoughts go out to the artists who
have never received this honor and even
though they work with enormous
commitment and talent to all of them he
wishes that their work would be
recognized as his is tonight
Teredo kpop we so premios yeah per may
no no punto de rêve oh man punto di
partenza per mil your army premiere army
al sur V so del Sima de al servicio on
que aunque de la mia person allah
Aesthetica allah sulla music apricot ax
he says disaster and not a point of
arrival but a starting point to continue
writing the same passion and dedication
his head since the very beginning on the
screen edgar cayce oscar Namie Amuro
Maria Jamie amo multisim ogre asado a
hero to t question me hey hola amylose
esta manera
Cristo premio and uncovered lady and
he's dedicating we dedicate this Oscar
to his wife Maria who has always been
there with him and all these years with
enormous commitment and love which he
feels the same for her Maria